okay so I'll be talking about
hierarchical clustering and okay so this
is a very classical and popular form of
data analysis and so why is it popular
basically because it captures this
structure of data at all scales
simultaneously it's a multi scale
structure and we have some nice
algorithms for doing this okay complete
linkage average linkage and so on the
problem though is that it's not
completely clear what these algorithms
are doing average linkage the various
linkage methods they do a bunch of steps
that individually seem innocuous they
keep merging things that are close
together and at the end they spit out a
tree but there's really no underlying
objective function that this tree
corresponds to which means for example
that it's really hard to pinpoint the
kinds of trees that they're producing or
to say that here's another algorithm
that's faster that's doing kind of the
same thing or for example to introduce
constraints and say we want the best
tree subject to these constraints so in
in other areas of machine learning just
having a loss function has been really
important and so it would be nice to
have something like this for trees as
well and so that was sort of the
motivation for for the work that I'll
describe today and so what I'll do is
I'll propose a a cost function for
hierarchies and then I'll give an
algorithm that you know that that
approximately minimizes this cost
function and then I'll show how it can
be used for various things like
interactive hierarchical clustering so
how would we come up with a cost
function so the input to hierarchical
clustering is a bunch of points say in
Euclidean space or more generally in a
metric space or most generally of all
just a bunch of similarities between
points okay so the input could be an N
by n similarity matrix
okay now to sort of keep things
pictorial I'll just assume that the
similarity matrix is given in the form
of a graph okay so over here there are
six data points and these are the ones
that are similar and again just for
simplicity over here all the
similarities are 0 or 1 but in general
they will be some sort of positive
numbers okay they'll be positive real
numbers and so this is the input
similarity and now we want to come up
with a cost function on trees so for
every possible tree we want to assign a
score okay and how would we do that
what's a reasonable cost function so um
so here's an idea okay so the edges over
here represent similarity so we don't
want to break those edges so why don't
we it's a tree constant edge then we
charge for that okay so that's a that's
a reasonable thing we don't want the
clusterings to cut edges but in a
hierarchical clustering you eventually
cut all the edges okay because at the
end you just end up with the individual
points so what we'll do instead is that
we will say that we charge for cutting
an edge and the charge is higher the
higher up that edge is cut okay so we
don't want to cut any of these edges but
if we cut an edge really high up in the
tree then we have a high charge for it
and if it's lower down in the trees then
there's a lower charge okay so let me
let's step through an example of what
this cost function would look like so
here's the input graph and now we want
to assign a cost to any any given tree
okay so here's a sample tree and we need
to say what is the numeric cost of this
tree okay so so let's look at the cuts
that this tree induces at the very top
it's separating 5 and 6 from 1 2 3 4 so
it's cutting this edge at the top ok
this is the edge that's got and since it
cuts one edge we'll get a charge of 1
that top split cost 1 the second split
on this side separates 1 and 3 from 2 &
4 so it cuts these ok so it cuts these 3
edges so we'd normally give it a charge
of 3 but at this point it's a little
lower down at this point only 2
thirds of the data remains that was six
points and at this point only four of
them are left so we get a discount so we
charge three times two thirds okay
on this side we separate five from six
so we cut this one edge so we charge one
for it but only one-third of the data
points we're remaining at this point so
we multiply that by a third okay and
film so if any questions just feel free
to ask yeah there's nothing in this
criteria which does anything about death
that's right actually are you going to
get very deep trees out of this
sometimes so it's quite possible but
we'll see so we'll see a bunch of things
related to depth for example it'll turn
out that the algorithm that I you know
talked about later would produce things
that are log n dip okay so so so here is
the cost function specifically okay so
you get charged for each edge it's the
weight of the edge times then the
fraction of data that was left when you
cut that edge so let's say there's an
edge between I and J okay so then it
there's an edge between two points I and
J when did that edge get cut at the
lowest common ancestor of I and J that's
when that edge got broken and you get
charged according to the number of leads
in that subtree okay the fraction of
data that was left when that edge was
cut so I'm not dividing by the end over
here just so that's the cost function on
trees and so let's look at some property
just to sanity checks okay because you
know we just are trying to cook up a
cost function from first principles and
this could easily you know lead to
something you know that doesn't have
that doesn't behave well on even very
simple cases okay so let's do some
sanity checks so the first thing to
observe is that there's always a binary
tree that is optimal okay so even if
that could there that could be several
optimal trees but if there's one that
looks like this
you can always just separate off one of
these sub
trees at a time and you will not
increase the cost okay so under this
cost function you can restrict attention
to binary trees
the second based basic similarity check
is that if the initial graph is
disconnected then you do have to start
by separating out those disconnected
components okay and so at least that's
true okay so now let's look at some more
concrete examples okay let's say you
have the graph let's say your input
similarity just a line graph on n nodes
what is the optimal tree in this case
okay so here are two candidate trees and
let's look at what that cost would be
this is the caterpillar tree that first
separates off one then separates off two
then separates our three and this is a
more balanced tree okay so for the
caterpillar tree this is the first edge
that you cut and when you cut it there
are n nodes left to get a cost of n for
it this is the second edge you cut and
when you cut that there were n minus one
nodes left this is the third edge and
when you cut it there n minus 2 nodes
lift so the total cost is n plus n minus
1 plus n minus 2 which is N squared so
the cost of this is N squared so this
one the first edge you cut is the one in
the middle and then there are M nodes
left the next one you touch other 25%
oil and 75 percentile edges and when you
cut those there were n over 2 lists and
so on and so now the cost is going to be
n log n ok so in this case this would be
N squared and so there's a strong
preference for the balanced one in this
case by by by a factor of n ok what I'll
show you in a second is the input of the
kiln it is written really an ingredient
and will favor
because the cause that every jump sure
is you know you want and note left and
the other one is multiplying and over
two by n over two first right so so
right so what you're saying is that if
we try to greedy algorithm where we
iteratively did minimum cut then it
would it would not so but it turns out
that that greedy algorithm will also not
give a good approximation to the to the
subjective and so we'll have to use a
different type of greedy Albert okay
so a key property is that it if the
input is the complete graph then all
trees have exactly the same cost okay so
if the input is a complete graph so
there is no nothing is more similar than
anything else then every tree has
exactly the same cost and it turns out
that a lot of other things having to do
with this cost function really rely
heavily on this property so cancel and
I'll explain why that's true in a second
so one of the things that implies for
example is that if you try running this
on a planted partition model then in
expectation it does exactly the right
thing and with high probability it comes
close to doing the right thing okay so
let me just explain this property a
little more why is it that under this
cost function if you start with a
complete graph every tree that you can
think of has exactly the same cost every
binary tree okay and so I'll just step
through the argument very closely okay
so so we have this graph which is a
clique okay and each time for every edge
we're going to charge the number of
nodes that will last when that edge was
broken okay so that means that for each
edge we charge at most N and there are n
choose two edges okay so an upper bound
on the cost is n cubed is actually n
times n choose two let us make it NQ
okay so that's an upper bound on the
cost now we get a specific tree and we
haven't looked at the tree yet but we
know it's cost is at most n cubed okay
we are going to bound the cost of the
tree by just
um revealing it one note at a time so we
have this screen we haven't looked at it
yet we know its cost is at most n cubed
and now we're going to open up the soft
node of the tree the top split and then
we'll open up the second split and so on
we'll gradually reveal the tree ok we
have an unknown tree and we're going to
reveal one split at a time and after
we've reveal.js
splits we look at the cost of the
remaining part okay and whatever is left
whatever we haven't looked at we're
going to bound by this n cubed type
thing okay so initially we haven't
opened up anything in the tree and so an
upper bound on the cost is n cubed let's
say that we open up J splits and the
Jade split the jth node from the top of
the tree has a set of size M that it
splits into two sets of size K and M
minus K okay so now before we unveiled
that split we were charging M cubed we
didn't know what was going on we said
enough abound on the cost is M cubed
once we've opened up that split an upper
bound on the unknown cost is K cubed
plus n minus K cubed okay so this is how
much the upper bound has changed M cubed
minus K cubed plus M minus K cube which
is this amount and that specific cost
that we've opened up so the specific
split that we revealed what is its cost
well there were M nodes left at the time
and this is the number of edges across
the split so it's exactly the change in
the upper bound divided by three and in
this way we go all the way down the tree
initially the unknown cost was n cubed
by the time we left at the bottom we
have these n individual nodes each with
a cost of 1 cubed which is 1 and there's
n of them so this is the cost at the
bottom of the tree and and so the
overall cost of the tree the cost of all
the splits is is just the sum of these
quantities in the two telescoping sum
and so it's the initial upper bound
minus the final upper bound divided by 3
and it's n cubed minus n over 3 ok so no
matter what tree you use you end up with
exactly the same cost okay which is a
and this turns out to be a helpful
property for showing many other things
about this cost function okay so so
we've shown that it has some reasonable
properties and it does something okay
with the planted partition model but all
of this would be meaningless if we
didn't have an algorithm for it okay and
so the first thing is that it's an
np-hard problem okay and this is sad but
it was certainly to be expected because
all the other clustering cost functions
we know K Center K means they're already
hard okay so be weird if it won't work
so we'll so we have to look at
heuristics okay so here's a very natural
heuristic you have this input similarity
graph why don't you just do a spectral
by partitioning of that graph okay so
you get two pieces and make that the top
split and then you recurse on the two
sides okay why don't we give that a try
okay so the input is this weighted graph
and you recursively do sparse cut okay
so here's the algorithm you do sparse Oh
Scott and then you recurse on the two
sides
now it's parses cut is again something
that is np-hard but we have lots of
approximation algorithms for this we
have the spectral relaxation we have the
LP relaxation the semi-definite
relaxation so the plenty of algorithms
for this listing we just use whatever
our favorite is which is some alpha
approximation to the sparse Oh Scott it
turns out that if you do this then
overall you get an alpha log n
approximation to this cost function and
and I'll explain why okay so it's a very
simple algorithm you just do and this is
something that actually has been
suggested in many other contexts
recursive spectral partitioning or maybe
not the spectral God but you know any
any sort of approximation to sparse
let's cut and if you do this then you
get an approximate solution to to this
hierarchical clustering problem okay and
so let me explain briefly why that is
the case where is this alpha log n
coming from
is this true even if alpha zero so if
you have anything that parses cut do I
get an exact solution to across function
yeah so then alpha will be one in that
case yeah yeah so it did so that right
so this that's right which will get an
approximation but one thing that I will
so there been some improved results but
I've also talked about in this tank
right yes I did this create bounce to
the algorithm tends to create log in
depth trees right and understand why
this rule does right so we'll move you
that in a second okay and yeah so the
kind of the weird thing over here is
that the algorithm that we are using is
this is sparse this cut where you're
looking at the ratio of the number of
edges got divided by the number of nodes
on each side you're looking at a ratio
and there's nothing of the cost function
that suggests a ratio at all it's just
because it's hierarchical that you need
to bet that you need to do these ratio
cuts in order to in order to get an
approximation by Parsons
for your objective function or we use
there sure I mean use this you're saying
that me let's say we just look at one
eigenvector that gives us sort of M
candidate cuts right and we just pick
whichever one with whichever one had the
best objective yeah so that's exactly
what you were doing this case um you'd
use this partial Scott objective yeah
because CT is for the overall tree so it
doesn't really say anything about
and of course sonically normalization so
absolutely and what it would be exactly
the same thing and so I'll actually
present a generalized form of the cost
function very soon okay so I'm so here
the argument right so so so we have this
cost function that applies to entire
trees and now we are sort of greedily
constructing it by by doing one split at
a time but but you know in this
recursive way so what you can show with
1 1 1 why are we doing sparse this
couple what you can show is that pick
any tree you like if the tree has low
cost then there exists a cut of the
grass that is balanced one-third
two-third balanced and such that the
sparsity of that cut the number of edges
across divided by the number of nodes on
the left and the number of nodes on the
right is also very small so if the tree
has small cost there exists a a cut that
is balanced and has small sparsity
proportional to the cost of that tree ok
and this is sort of the key thing you
need of course in any greedy scheme and
so why is that the case so you have this
tree let's say the optimal tree and the
tree starts by splitting the graph into
ok but that but the tree split might not
be a balanced split that optimal tree
who knows maybe it's got you know just
10% of the nodes on one side and 90% on
the other ok so the optimal tree might
have just 10% on this side and 90% on
this side in which case we keep going
let's see what the tree does next oh we
only cut off 5% this time
85% on this side and we keep going until
we accumulate at least a third of the
points on one side ok and so you end up
with at least a ton of the points over
here and at least 2/3 of the points over
here and that's the cut we're going to
look at initially this versus the union
of these ok so that's what we are going
to that's the cut a be
okay so we pick the smallest K such that
we get at least n over three points over
here and the cut we're going to look at
whose sparsity we're going to bound is
that a on one side and all of these on
the other and so they each have size at
least n over three so it's a balanced
cut and now this is the tree the optimal
tree the edges across the cut are
contained in these edges and so the cost
of the tree in the in this optimal tree
every one of these edges was cut at a
point where at least two-thirds of the
nodes were still present okay so for
every one of these edges the cost was at
least two n over three so the overall
cost of the tree is at least 2 n over 3
times the edges across that cut and so
that's all we so that's what we get over
there and so we're in a situation where
you get a cut that's balanced you know
it shrinks the size of the data by a
constant factor and the and and we can
bound the cost relative to the optimal
tree and see a golden basically you can
just keep applying this okay and so this
gives the alpha log n factor and and
there's also you can look at a
generalized cost function where where
you can where you have some other
function of the of the number of
descendants so instead of looking at you
know so they're supposed to say well you
know instead of looking at the fraction
of the points that were left when the
edge was got what if we want to look at
the log of the fraction or the fraction
squared or something like that okay and
you can do something similar for all of
those ok so now in terms of theory
results they've been some beautiful more
recent work so Moses cherry car and
Vagos chat via ferrata showed that the
algorithm you know that I thought was a
log in of alpha log n approximation
actually just an alpha approximation
there's a certain looseness in the
analysis okay so it's actually you know
it's actually a lot better than expected
and then there's a very interesting
result by Varun kannada vincent kona
dodd and claire math here which said
that look you know in in many contexts
like in phylogenetics you know what we
okay a cost function is fine but we also
want some sort of recovery guarantee
that you know there's a there's a tree
we want and we want to make sure we're
getting the right tree so in particular
the sort of metrics that arise in the
context of phylogenetic SAR altra
metrics those are the distance functions
and let's say your original similarity
graph came from an ultra metric so those
similar similarity values are decreasing
functions of the ultra metric distances
okay whatever the decreasing function is
okay so a similarity graph has been
generated but as some decreasing
function of ultra metric values what can
you say about the tree and it turns out
that the tree that minimizes this cost
function is the generating tree for the
for the ultimate clique okay so it's a
recovery properly and that's a very nice
result
okay so how does this thing work well I
tried it out on a very sort of a fun
data set called animals with attributes
which is something like 75 animals each
of which has 75 features and these
features are things like furry 4 legs
you know that kind of stuff
okay so in the 75 animals it's 75
attributes you can just run the
algorithm on it very easily and you get
something okay a hierarchical clustering
of the animals it looks great to me you
know horse and deer and antelope here a
seal killer whale dolphin looks great
so as far as I'm concerned this is
wonderful but it turns out that like
from the biologists point of view there
are definitely some mistakes in here
okay and but it's very close okay and so
we also tried average linkage and then
also did very well very similar okay
so and so then the question is you know
like what's the point then you know it's
like okay we put all this effort into
finding a cost function we try to prove
some stuff about it and we have this
algorithm now and you know it does kind
of like whatever shrinkage is doing was
there any point to the whole exercise
and I think there was let me explain
what I do we do know what what it is the
first is that average linkage although a
wonderful algorithm is quadratic and
that means that you simply cannot run it
on very large data set you know a
hundred thousand points for instance
this on the other hand because it's top
down you can look for quick and dirty
ways of doing the sparse cut in linear
time and so potentially get an algorithm
that's only n log N and so there are
actually many ways in which one could
try and do this and this is something
that we are investigating the other
thing the other rationale for having the
cost function is that you can then do
constrained hierarchical clustering and
I'll just give you two examples of that
why would you want to put constraints
into hierarchical clustering here's an
example suppose you wanted the
clustering to be interpretable like you
say each split has to be on a single
feature that's easy if you have a cost
function you just say instead of doing
arbitrary splits minimize the cost over
splits of a certain type and then you
get an interpretable hierarchy okay
first check if the animal is quadruped
it'll and how good pause I don't know
what meet these kids but anyway they
these are some of the features of this
data is it okay the the other sort of
thing that the other kind of constraint
hierarchical clustering that I'm very
interested in is sort of interactive
hierarchical clustering and I'll just
say a couple of words about that you
know I I really love unsupervised
learning a lot you know but I do feel
that you know when done right it gives
you something that's close to what you
want but it can never really give you
exactly what you want okay just you know
even in the animal example there are
really a lot of ways
hierarchically cluster animals you could
be trying to get the Linnaean taxonomy
or some sort of geographic based
hierarchy or just how cute they are I
mean these are all legitimate okay and
there is just no way that an
unsupervised algorithm can figure out
which of these you actually want okay so
you can get close but you're never
actually going to get the one you want
and so for that you do need some
interaction okay and once you have a
cost function that's not so hard to do
okay so what we did is we started with
that tree that animals with attributes
tree that I showed you that looks pretty
good to me but you know it has
apparently got some mistakes and then we
started an interactive procedure so what
is the interaction on each round you
randomly pick ten elements and ten
animals and then you show the hierarchy
restricted to those game animals okay
because this is really too big to look
at in one go so you pick ten animals at
random and then you show the hierarchy
restricted to just those ten animals and
then you ask the expert which is not me
but you are the expert does this
hierarchy look good and for example over
here although it seems fine there are
some problems okay and here is one so it
turns out that there should be a cluster
that contains Tiger and Kali but not
gorilla okay maybe this make sense to
some of you that Tiger and Kali should
be together in some subtree that does
not include gorilla okay that's one of
the things of the correct taxonomy and
so what happens is that the expert looks
at this picture looks at this random
snapshot and then type fixes a little
part of it types in this constraint and
this then gets thrown into the just get
thrown in as a constraint and then you
can say minimize the same loss function
subject to this constraint and it turns
out that algorithmically that is quite
easy to do using some tricks that people
in phylogenetics have developed because
you know they have actually also been
interested in dealing with constraints
of this kind and so you throw in the
constraint and then you get a
modified tree that satisfies that
constraint okay so now Tiger and Kali
are together over here and gorillas
apart from them and in this case you do
this a few times and you get you get the
right tree okay so I think this is a
very you know there's a very useful way
of improving a hierarchical cluster okay
yeah right so what happened
right so what happens is the cost
function remains the same but now there
are these additional hard constraints so
it says okay the tree has to have some
subtree that has these two but not this
complete with all of my columns or MIT
either be the original cost function is
formatted the way that I write or the
algorithm SportsNation your inputs and I
could not see the right
we're getting better wage I mean you can
think of that original cost function as
essentially some kind of regular writer
okay it's you know a reasonable cost
function on trees you know
it's certainly not going to give you the
right tree you know right off the bat it
has no idea exactly what it is that you
want but then if you throw in a few
constraints it's like a regularizer it
you know it does something reasonable
subject to those constraints claim
interact with the seekers did call the
parcel skirt right so that's right okay
so that's the algorithmic issue of how
we actually incorporate these
constraints and it seems a little bit
tricky you know but it turns out that
these constraints like this are very
hard to incorporate into a bottom-up
scheme but if it you have a top-down
algorithm it's quite easy to incorporate
these constraints and this is just using
it that there are some standard tricks
that that I used to this yeah
you know I mean you know this is
actually just a toy example but but I
think that and this is a very specific
form of interaction I think ultimately
what would be needed it's like a handful
of different types of interaction
because sometimes it might be feature
based like you say you know you really
need to be looking at the Quadra
portable thing or something like that
right and so that would be a different
type of interaction and a slightly
different type of constraint and it
would be worth having a scheme for them
so you know hopefully there'd be a
handful of these different constraint
types that would actually cover quite a
few cases that arise in in applications
so why don't you put the constraints
into the PDF some initial graph right
but you could have waited edges in the
graph you could actually learn to
predict what the weight is it should be
in the graph right and then you can
imagine you putting the constraint in is
an example about what similarity and
dissimilarity and then you could
generalize from needing to specify
constraint for every violation of the
initial cost function to only specify
have to use it because you can kind of
adjust a very large graph in a very
small amount of time right so right so
the question there is about is about you
know here's another way to use the
constraints which is to actually learn
the similarity function right and that's
and that's another thing that you know
that's another thing that could be done
so so one one point worth mentioning is
that you don't actually end up
correcting every for in the initial tree
just because there's this kind of you
know there's a domino effect
the question books before because the
oven that used produced the trade is
itself an approximation of perfectly
useful like that not get the perfect
intersection away from government only
the question really becomes from an
interactive learning what's the most
efficient way to get to the final light
tree did it using query that you can
change to go back in the correct
direction
and Larry which might then sort of do
prove a better result
yeah I'm not sure actually you know we
thought both these things similarity
matrices and hierarchical clustering
these are the complete that you know
sort of the bit words for hierarchical
clustering something like n log M and
for a similarity matrix or something
like M Squared suitable you know fairly
complicated objects and you know we can
regularize heavily but in both cases you
would need quite a few example if that's
all you were using you know and so
that's that that's something that really
does come up a lot in interaction like
there are certain types of interaction
that had small local effects there are
types of interactions that have more
trickled out effects and then there are
type that actually sort of big
sledgehammers that make you know that
caused a big global change and and you
know it's kind of it would be
interesting to try to quantify these
things and yeah absolutely so I'm in
terms of open problems there are lots of
them but I'll just say one very quickly
which is you know this was a case where
there really was a lack of cost function
and so you know it made sense to
introduce one but I also think there are
many cases in which we already have cost
functions in which it makes sense to
look for other ones especially in a lot
of unsupervised learning the way we
actually come up with a cost function is
we posit a probabilistic model mixture
of gaussians Lda and so on and then the
cost function is simply the log
likelihood
sort of given to us automatically but
this can be unsatisfactory in some ways
some of those assumptions we have to
build into that probabilistic model are
a little bit hard to swallow and perhaps
unnecessary and very often that
log-likelihood cost function that we end
up with is just a huge mess and you know
we just you know algorithmically it's
not something we want to deal with we
look at it it looks horrible and so we
just say well we just kind of use local
search or you know EMI don't want to
have to you know try and deal directly
with this I think that there really is
you know there's possibly something to
be gained by actually looking at cases
where we ostensibly already have these
cost functions like these log
likelihoods of various types of models
and just go in and think you know is
there something similar that seems to be
capturing some of the same thing that we
could actually algorithmically deal with
and not just pass off to TEM okay thank
you very much if you have statistical
data right to suppose you have some
density function then
of course to make sense in this case so
are you talking about the setting where
the data you get is generated from some
distribution right right did you get
data generated from some distribution I
think a lot a lot depends on how you
construct that graph and so I think a
very interesting question would be
supposed to data points are generated
iid from some density
how would you construct the graph so
that the you know so this loss function
would actually converge ultimately to
something meaningful
I don't know no idea
yes regenerate the similarities from
contagion experiments so you need a
graph that actually has similarity yeah
so this so in those particular expanded
animal experiments this is a very simple
data set you know it's like whatever 80
animals and 80 attributes and these are
all binary attributes you know to walk
on two legs or not walk on two legs so
you should get dot products I mean the
the idea was not to try and get great
performance on it or anything it's just
to like quickly it's like basically as a
quick sanity check
oh you mean to to to compare different
hierarchies on the basis of this cost
you know I would yeah I you know I
wouldn't cost function is just something
I cooked up last year you know I mean I
wouldn't tell you know I don't see it as
a you know as a rigorous basis for
comparison comparing different
hierarchical clustering algorithm
something that would be a lot more
compelling to me is you know if we
actually had a nice testbed of
hierarchical clustering datasets you
know and and then we could compare
against the gold standard or something
like that so that would be nice
unfortunately I don't think we had a
testbed of that kind there are a few
datasets where there is this natural
hierarchical structure like this animals
data but will be nice if there were more
about the inverse problem like to have a
three what are the ultimate success
actually we'll harvest
for what other possible similarities I
heard problem can one whole society
right so um so what happens right so so
relating back to ultra metrics over
there the starting point um you know the
phylogenetic trees the way in which it
differs from hierarchical clustering is
that you don't just have a tree but you
also have lengths on the edges and so
that so so I guess one could talk about
as as human those lengths are strictly
greater than zero
you know so um what is the range of
similarities that you would get from
that yeah and then this is something
that was actually touched upon quite a
bit in but on canadaís what
yeah so I mean currently so right okay
so about the stability of the loss
function right as opposed to the
specific algorithm so the the various
some sort of greedy heuristics you could
use to find the cut has very different
stability properties for example the
spectral ones can be wildly unstable
whereas some of the semi definite based
ones are probably a lot more stable
lovely something that would be really
interesting to to figure out you know
both the stability of the loss function
itself inherently and of these specific
splitting made methods
[Applause]